Hola.
Me gustaría presentarles a alguien.
Este es Jomny.
Como "Jonny" pero escrito accidentalmente con una "m",
por si se lo preguntan,
ya que no todos somos perfectos.
Jomny es un extraterrestre
que fue enviado a la Tierra con la misión de estudiar a los humanos.
Jomny se siente perdido, solo y lejos de su casa,
y creo que todos nos hemos sentido así alguna vez.
O, al menos yo sí.
Escribí esta historia sobre este extraterreste en un momento de mi vida
en que me sentía muy extraño.
Acababa de mudarme a Cambridge para empezar un doctorado en el MIT,
me sentía intimidado y aislado. y me parecía estar fuera de lugar.
Pero tenía una especie de salvavidas.
Les cuento que hace muchos años que vengo escribiendo chistes
y los publico en las redes sociales.
Me di cuenta que lo estaba haciendo cada vez más.
Para muchas personas, Internet puede parecer un lugar solitario.
Puede parecer algo así,
un vacío grande, interminable y amplio
donde uno puede llamar sin cesar, sin que nadie lo escuche.
Pero en realidad encontré consuelo al hablar al vacío.
Descubrí que, al compartir mis sentimientos con el vacío,
el vacío comenzó a responder.
Resulta que el vacío no es para nada una extensión solitaria sin fin,
en cambio está lleno de todo tipo de personas,
también mirándolo y queriendo ser escuchados.
Han habido muchas cosas malas venidas de la mano de las redes sociales.
No trato de ponerlo en duda para nada.
Hay momentos que estar en línea es sentir tanta tristeza,
tanta ira y tanta violencia.
Puede sentirse como el fin del mundo.
Y a la vez, me siento en un conflicto
porque no puedo negar el hecho de que muchos de mis amigos más cercanos
son personas que conocí originalmente en línea.
Creo que eso se debe en parte a la naturaleza confesional
de las redes sociales.
Puede parecer que uno escribe en un diario personal e íntimo
que es completamente privado,
pero al mismo tiempo queremos que lo lean todos en el mundo.
Pienso que parte de eso, la alegría que trae
es que podemos experimentar cosas desde la perspectiva de otros
que son totalmente distintos a nosotros,
que puede ser algo agradable.
Por ejemplo, cuando me uní a Twitter,
descubrí que muchas personas a quienes seguía
hablaban de salud mental y de ir a terapia
sin tener el mismo estigma que se suele tener
cuando hablamos de estos temas en persona.
A través de ellos, la conversación sobre la salud mental se normalizó,
y me ayudaron a darme cuenta de que ir a terapia
era algo que también me ayudaría.
Ahora, para mucha gente,
parece una idea aterradora hablar sobre todos estos temas
tan pública y abiertamente en Internet.
Siento que mucha gente piensa que es algo grande y aterrador
estar en línea si aún no está perfectamente y completamente formado.
Pero creo que Internet puede ser un gran lugar para no saberlo,
y creo que podemos tratar eso con entusiasmo,
porque para mí hay algo importante en compartir nuestras imperfecciones,
nuestras inseguridades y nuestras vulnerabilidades
con otras personas.
(Risas)
Ahora, cuando alguien comparte que se siente triste o asustado
o solo, por ejemplo,
en realidad me hace sentir menos solo,
no librándome de mi soledad
pero mostrándome que no estoy solo
al sentirme solo.
Y como escritor y como artista,
me importa mucho hacer que este consuelo de ser vulnerable
algo comunal, algo que podemos compartir entre nosotros.
Me entusiasma poder externalizar lo interno,
tomar esos sentimientos personales invisibles para los que no tengo palabras,
mostrarlos a la luz, nombrarlos con palabras,
y luego compartirlos con otras personas
para así ayudarles a encontrar palabras para poder definir sus sentimientos.
Sé que eso suena como algo grande,
pero estoy interesado en poner todas estas cosas
en paquetes pequeños y accesibles,
porque al esconderlos en estas piezas más pequeñas,
son más fáciles de abordar, creo que son más divertidos.
Creo que pueden ayudarnos más fácilmente a ver nuestra humanidad compartida.
A veces eso toma la forma de una narración breve,
a veces la de un lindo libro de ilustraciones, por ejemplo.
Y a veces toma la forma
de una broma tonta que lanzaré en Internet.
Por ejemplo, hace unos meses publiqué la idea de una aplicación
para un servicio para pasear perros
donde se les aparece un perro en la puerta y tienen que salir de la casa
para llevarlo a pasear.
(Risas)
Si hay desarrolladores de aplicaciones en la audiencia,
búsquenme después de la charla.
Les comento que cada vez que me siento ansioso al enviar un correo electrónico,
o cuando lo firmo con un "todo lo mejor",
que significa "este es mi mejor esfuerzo",
la abreviatura de "por favor no me odien odien, prometo que hago mejor que puedo.
O mi respuesta al rompehielos clásico,
si pudiera cenar con alguien, vivo o muerto, lo haría.
Estoy muy solo.
(Risas)
Y cuando publico cosas como estas en línea,
la reacción es muy parecida.
La gente se une para compartir una risa,
para compartir ese sentimiento,
y luego desaparecer con la misma rapidez.
(Risas)
Sí, dejándome solo de nuevo.
Pero a veces estas pequeñas reuniones pueden ser bastante significativas.
Por ejemplo, cuando me gradué de la carrera de arquitectura
y me mudé a Cambridge,
publiqué esta pregunta:
"¿Con cuántas personas conocidas ya han tenido
su última conversación? "
Y pensé en mis propios amigos que se habían mudado
a diferentes ciudades y hasta diferentes países,
y cuán difícil sería para mí mantenerme en contacto con ellos.
Otras personas comenzaron a responder y compartir sus propias experiencias.
Alguien habló sobre un familiar con quien se habían peleado.
De un ser querido que había fallecido
de forma rápida e inesperada.
Alguien de sus amigos de la escuela.
quienes se habían alejado también.
Y entonces empezó a suceder algo realmente agradable.
En vez de solo responderme a mí,
la gente comenzó a responderse entre sí,
y comenzaron a hablar entre ellos, a compartir sus propias experiencias,
a consolarse entre sí
y a alentarse mutuamente para acercarse a ese amigo
con quien no hablaban desde hace mucho,
o ese familiar con quien se pelearon.
Y finalmente, logramos esta pequeña microcomunidad.
Se sintió como si se hubiera creado un grupo de apoyo
a partir de la unión de todo tipo de personas.
Creo que cada vez que publicamos algo en línea,
cada vez que lo hacemos, hay una posibilidad
de crear unas pequeñas microcomunidades.
Existe la posibilidad de que todo tipo de criaturas diferentes
puedan acercarse y unirse.
Y a veces, en el medio de la basura que hay en Internet,
podemos encontrar un espíritu afín.
A veces es al leer las respuestas y los comentarios
cuando podemos encontrar una respuesta particularmente amable
o perspicaz o divertida.
A veces sucede al seguir a alguien
y ver que ya nos siguen.
A veces eso es mirar a alguien que conocemos en la vida real
y ver las cosas que escribimos y lo que escriben
y viendo que compartimos muchos de los mismos intereses,
y eso nos acerca más.
A veces, si uno tiene suerte,
se puede encontrar a otro alienígena.
[cuando 2 alienígenas se encuentran en un lugar extraño, es como estar en casa]
Pero también me preocupa, ya que, como sabemos,
la mayoría de Internet no se siente así.
Todos sabemos que en su mayor parte,
Internet se siente como un lugar donde nos entendemos mal,
donde entramos en conflicto entre nosotros,
donde hay todo tipo de confusión, gritos, chillidos e insultos
y parece que hay demasiado de todo.
Se siente como un caos
y no sé cómo cuadrar las partes malas con las buenas,
porque como sabemos y como hemos visto,
las partes malas pueden lastimarnos de verdad.
Me parece que las plataformas que usamos para habitar estos espacios en línea
fueron diseñadas de forma ignorante o intencional
para permitir el acoso y el abuso, para propagar información errónea,
para permitir odio y discurso de odio y la violencia que proviene de él,
y parece que ninguna de las plataformas actuales
hacen lo suficiente para abordar y arreglar eso.
Pero aún así, y quizás desafortunadamente,
todavía me atraen estos espacios en línea, como muchos otros,
porque a veces parece que es donde están todas las personas.
Y me siento tonto
y estúpido, a veces,
por valorar estos pequeños momentos de conexión humana en momentos como estos.
Siempre me manejé bajo esta idea
que estos pequeños momentos de humanidad no son superfluos.
No son retiros del mundo en absoluto,
sino que son el motivo por el que venimos a estos espacios.
Son importantes, vitales; afianzan y nos dan vida.
Y son estos pequeños santuarios temporales.
que nos muestran que no estamos tan solos como creemos.
Entonces, aunque la vida es mala y todos están tristes
y un día nos vamos a morir,
[mira. la vida es mala. todos están tristes.
todos moriremos. ya compré este castillo hinchable
entonces, ¿te quitas los zapatos o no?]
Creo que el castillo hinchable metafórico en este caso
son realmente nuestras relaciones y conexiones con los demás.
Así una noche,
cuando me sentía supertriste y sin esperanza por el mundo,
grité al vacío
a la solitaria oscuridad.
Dije: "En este punto, iniciar una sesión en las redes sociales
es como tomar la mano de alguien en el fin del mundo ".
Y entonces, en vez del vacío,
fueron las personas las que aparecieron,
quienes comenzaron a responderme y quienes luego hablaron entre sí.
Y lentamente se formó una pequeña comunidad.
Todos se unieron para tomarse de las manos.
En estos tiempos peligrosos e inseguros,
en medio de todo esto,
creo que a lo que tenemos que aferrarnos es a otras personas.
Sé que es una cosa pequeña, hecha de pequeños momentos,
pero creo que es una pequeña luz
en toda la oscuridad
Gracias.
(Aplausos)